hi and welcome back you've seen by now
that changin your net can involve
setting a lot of different hyper
parameters now how do you go about
finding a good setting for these hyper
parameters in this video I want to share
with you some guidelines some tips how
to systematically organize your hyper
parameter tuning process which hopefully
will make it more efficient for you to
converge on a good setting of the hyper
parameters one of the painful things
about training deep nets is the sheer
number of hyper parameters you have to
deal with ranging from the learning rate
alpha to the momentum term beta the
using momentum or the hyper parameters
for the atom optimization algorithm
which were beta 1 beta 2 and epsilon
maybe have to pick the number of layers
maybe have to pick the number of hidden
units for the different layers and maybe
you want to use learning rate decay so
you don't just use a single learning
rate alpha and then of course you might
need to choose the mini batch size so it
turns out some of these parameters are
more important than others for most
learning applications I would say alpha
the learning rate is the most important
hyper parameter to tune other than alpha
a few other high performances I tend to
but maybe to Nick's would be maybe the
momentum term I say is 0.9 is a good
default and also tune the mini batch
size to make sure that the optimization
algorithm is running efficiently often
also fit around the hidden units of the
ones I've circled in orange these are
really the three that would consider
second in importance to the learning
rate alpha and then third in importance
you know after sitting around the others
the number of layers can sometimes make
a huge difference and so can learning
rate decay and then when using the atom
algorithm I actually pretty much never
tune beta-1 beta-2 an epsilon pretty
much always used point nine point nine
nine nine and ten to the minus eight
although you can try tuning those as
well if you wish but hopefully does give
you some rough sense of what type of
parameters might be
more important than others alpha most
important for sure
follow maybe by the ones I've circled in
orange follow maybe by the ones I
circled in purple but this isn't a hard
and fast rule and I think other deep
learning practitioners may well disagree
with you all have different intuitions
on these now if you're trying to tune
some set of high preferences how do you
select the set of values to explore in
earlier generations of machine learning
algorithms if you had to hyper
parameters which I'm calling how to
prime to one and have a ground to to
here it was common practice to sample
the points you know in a grid like so
and systematically explore these values
here I'm placing down a five by five
grid in practice it could be more or
less than five five grid but you try out
in this example or twenty five points
and then you know pick whichever hyper
parameter works best and this practice
works okay when the number of
hyperparameters was relatively small
indeed learning what we tend to do and
what I recommend you do instead is
choose the points at random so go ahead
and you know choose maybe your same
number of points all right 25 points and
then try out the hyper parameters on
this randomly chosen set of points and
the reason you do that is that it's
difficult to know in advance which hyper
parameters are going to be the most
important for your problem and as you
saw in the previous slide some hyper
parameters are actually much more
important than others so to take an
example let's say hyper parameter one
turns out to be alpha the learning rate
and to take an extreme example let's say
that hyper parameter two was that value
epsilon that you have in the denominator
of the atom algorithm so your choice of
alpha matters a lot in your choice of
epsilon hardly matters so if you sample
in a grid then you've really tried out
five values of alpha and you might find
that all of the different values of
epsilon gives you essentially the same
answer
so you've now trained 25 models and only
got them to try out five values for the
learning rate alpha which is the thing
that's really important whereas in
contrast if you were to sample a random
then you know you all have tried out
twenty-five distinct values of the
learning rate alpha and therefore you'd
be more likely to find a value that
works really well I've explained this
example using just two hyper parameters
in practice you might be searching over
many more hyper parameters than this so
if you have safety hyper parameters I
guess instead searching over a square
you're searching over a cube where this
third dimension is hyper parameter three
and then by sampling within this you
know three dimensional tube you get to
try out a lot more values of each of
your three high parameters and in
practice you might be searching over
even more hyper parameters than three
and sometimes it's just hard to know in
advance which ones turn out to be the
really important high parameters for
your application and something random
rather than in a grid and it shows that
you're more richly exploring the pot set
of possible values for the most
important hyper parameters whether they
turn out to be when you stand for hyper
parameters another common practice is to
use a course to find something scheme so
let's say in this two-dimensional
example that you've sampled these points
and maybe you found that this point work
the best it may be a few other points
around it tended to work really well
then in the course defined scheme what
you might do is zoom in to a smaller
region of the hyper parameters and then
sample more densely within this space or
maybe a gain at random but to then focus
more resources on searching within this
blue square if you're suspecting that
the best setting of the hyper parameters
may be in this region so after doing a
core sample of this entire square that
tells you to then focus on on a smaller
square you can then stop pull more
densely in this smallest square so this
type of a course to find search is also
frequently use and by trying out these
different values of the high parameters
you can then
pick whatever value allows you to do
best on your training set objective or
does best on your development sets or
whatever you're trying to optimize in
your hyper parameter search process so
hope this gives you a way to more
systematically organize your hyper
parameter search process the two key
takeaways are used random something not
a grid search and consider optionally
but consider implementing a course
defined search process but there's even
more to hyper parameter search than this
let's talk more in the next video about
how to choose the right scale on which
to sample your hyper parameters